[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Thursday I am
Johnny well joined by Ben we're back
again we're back again they couldn't
keep us away Persia is still not feeling
well so we're filling in for her and we
got treat for you because we have Final
Fantasy 7 remake heck yes yeah we are
gonna play an hour the game and we're
gonna be going through a a spoiler free
version of sort of like the the first
opening part once you get to do some
side missions is what we're gonna be
doing today you're gonna be you're be
taking me on a journey because I just
finished my first playthrough 7 so I'm
just I'm ready for it yeah so so for
those who were worried like don't worry
we're this is not gonna cover any like
of the big story stuff this is all side
missions stuff it's just gonna be a good
example to kind of wander around do some
stuff show off the game answer any
questions chat with you guys about Final
Fantasy Ben what do you think about
Final Fantasy uh as a person who like I
said had just finished the first
playthrough recently and this is what
are my most anticipated games this year
now I'm really excited to like play it
cool also I am getting notifications
that frames are dropping please let me
know if the stream is being an issue and
I'll try and troubleshoot it okay so
this this is a you're in the the slums
area yes so this is this is the opening
of the game this is like after you've
done the opening where you like go to
the the first macro reactor that was in
the demo some story stuff happened and
now we're here in the sector seven slums
we're hanging out with our girl Tifa and
she's gonna fall we're gonna do some
side stuff
so yeah I have loved it a whole quest
here let's go let's go talk to that
little girl some people say in Final
Fantasy 8 is very good - that's actually
the next Final Fantasy I think I want to
play through cuz at this point I'm kind
of like art cool play remake some real
jazzed up about that my next logical
thing is to choose what my next Final
Fantasy game is that I'm gonna play
because I want to play more yeah I just
ran SIA attles this game run 4k 60 do
you know like the tech specs of it I
don't know the exact tech specs it's not
I don't know if it's like a solid 60 but
it it's pretty smooth it especially in
combat I've never run into really any
major frame drops I want to say it's a
little better than 30 but I don't know
if it's like a full 16 yeah yeah my
experience the game it's pretty smooth I
haven't really run into too many like
frame drops or anything
look.we chameleon yes how long is the
game I haven't played remake but I've
played I played the original one so I'm
not it took me of like 38 hours it took
two more 40 who reviewed it and go check
out his review it took him 40 I am not
done with it yet actually I'm gonna try
and finish it tonight and I'm currently
at like 28 hours so I think yeah my
final time will probably sit somewhere
if I had a guess just based on what I've
heard of how much I have left probably
like 35 to 40 will be the total for me
yeah that's what it seems like a lot of
people have been saying okay so this
little girl wants to find all her cats
there's a guy over here with some rat
problems classic video game sidequest
mmm it would be good to remake it
I'm curious what one they do after they
finish all of this because there's so
much more to this game's story
after final fantasies because like the
whole thing like seven is kind of this
weird exception right we're like you
know they tease that we make thing back
with like the ps3 reveal it was like a
tech demo like it's got all this weird
history around it the idea of it being
remade and I just don't know if like I
know a lot of people really liked it but
like it doesn't have like this legendary
status that like seven does right here
that Prelude oh yeah oh there's some
really good some real good music remixes
in this that you like collect it's like
vinyl records I didn't I didn't know but
apparently the prelude was written in
just five minutes as an off thing really
like the prelude for all the Final
Fantasy games is just like a quick like
we need something to put here and he's
like okay I feel like that's how most
just wrote things come to these yeah
I've never played a Final Fantasy game
I'm 30 am I missing out Stephen I am
also thirty and I just will technically
have played through fourteen which is
like four Final Fantasy games I'm gonna
math it out that way uh but I just
played my first like real Final Fantasy
game and it was the original seven mhm
and if if you like RPGs I if you like
interesting characters and really good
music I'd say give it a go at the gap
the like current versions you can get
like Final Fantasy seven on the switch
for like ten bucks and just give it a go
see if you like it or not oh I heard a
cat that's barely a cat nearby soon be
my first Final Fantasy game also it
sounds like this is a good way to do
this was not it's not my first I tried
13 but I gave up on it and I didn't I
didn't care for it and then I tried 15
and I also gave up on it this is the
first Final Fantasy that I've liked and
got to play all the way through and
actually
really really like so for all intents
and purposes I would say if you've never
played a final fantasy where you've
tried some final fantasies and maybe
bounced top I do think this game is
worth giving a look because I figured
final fantasy just wasn't for me but I
really really like this game a whole lot
yeah it 7 the original 7 was a huge
surprise for me because I was like
there's no way I'm gonna like this and I
actually go so far as to like make fun
of it a long time ago just because I
tried playing it when I was really young
kid the games like what 20-something
years old now as a 97 yeah like 29 so I
just didn't I couldn't I couldn't do it
without using frame drops that is not
the game that is by stream there's some
some silly internet stuff going on if
you're seeing frame drops that Paul that
has nothing to do with the game that is
a hundred percent my stream right now
these these current working from home
conditions stop the stream for like half
a second so
[Music]
okay
is it is it back are we back alright
apologies fat hopefully the stream is a
little bit smoother now the adjustments
we've tinkered some things so yeah
hopefully that streams a little bit
smoother now let's just buy some this
guy's got potions for days but I have no
money I shouldn't I shouldn't buy all
that I forgot you started like no money
in this umm but yeah what we were
talking about what just first Final
Fantasy's yeah this is this is my my
first I would consider this to be like
my first Final Fantasy that I've really
gotten into I think it's fantastic
so I recommend it heck yeah um oh I
really didn't expect the excitement I
got a boost volume for a sec see you can
all hear this beautiful Jam okay pretty
sweet you like it you feel it have a
copy what
what is this time just peddling his
chocobo Nick it's so good there are my
yam very into it that's that's so much
anyway just want people who uh it's it's
really bad and I love it
it's such a bad remix of the chocobo
themes but I like can't stop listening
to it I I love that it's not only the
fact that they had someone listening to
it in the world but also someone's like
hey man you like my new mixtape check it
out see buddy bro found a cat look at
his cat I think I'm kind of on the topic
of first Final Fantasy games but I think
uh said I put out a tweet earlier cuz I
was curious what everyone else is kind
of like favorite Final Fantasy wasn't to
kind of like sell me on why I should
play it next mm-hmm
it's a kind of get an idea of where I
should go and just kind of seeing how
many people like so many different Final
Fantasy games is kind of really rad yeah
I mean that's something Final Fantasy
it's like I feel like you're guaranteed
to at least appreciate one of them
because they are kind of so different in
so many ways I don't know it's taken me
a while to find the one I liked but
turns out it was seven all along yeah so
when you when you do get around to it's
a finishing this do you think you might
go back and play the original I don't
know I are just gonna kind of wait for
the the rest of the remake stuff to come
out to kind of do it I don't know I was
kind of thinking about that like what
will I do I might maybe I'll play like
eight or nine instead there you go
so apparently I didn't but I was looking
up all sorts of Final Fantasies if I'm
learning all this like dumb new
information I'm sure everyone already
know
but I had no idea of that ten and seven
were connected by the same like timeline
oh I didn't know that here it's
apparently ten happens like a thousand
years in the past of seven oh okay she's
like one of the people on the ship that
you talk to is like their name is Shinra
and they're like oh I'm gonna think up
new I'm gonna start up in source and
that's literally what happens and then I
guess a thousand years from then
eventually seven happens I don't know if
that's like the extent of it but it's
wild that is wild night I had no idea I
no idea that was a thing job the music
musics real good man oh if anyone has
any questions by the way and they want
me to answer anything you want me to
look at my menu stuff I guess I could
show what I'm rocking right now it's
probably not that much because this is
again like right when you like first
start to get the option like buy stuff
and things like that so I'm pretty
limited I have the iron blade which is
the first weapon you get outside of the
Buster Sword it has like a triple slash
ability which is pretty cool and it has
the option for three materia slots I
have fire materia healing materia I have
this assessment area which is part of a
quest I have to do where I need to you
can use it to basically like look at the
stats of an enemy and then you can
figure out like what they're weak to and
it also gives you some flavor text then
I have a HP up I'm actually gonna swap
that right here with deadly dog is
assessed sense basically I guess like
figure out like health and yes yes yes
okay that's the same thing I read upon
daily dodge which is great ability where
you after you do a Dodge you can
immediately do like a little attack
after that's pretty good that looks like
something you'd have on all the time yes
it's pretty essential for cloud in my
um look for Tifa I need to buy some some
stuff for her I have uh the chakra I
might swap that I'm gonna give her HP up
because she has low HP than everyone ice
one and then I should buy like a I'll
put the chakra back on but I should buy
like a healing one for her I always in
I'm the kind of person who just puts a
healing one on everybody our abilities
tied to equipment can you learn them so
the way that they work is yeah you you
can do all your sword attacks normally
and then all of your like spells and
stuff are all from the materia you slot
in so yeah basically the way it works is
some abilities are tied to the weapon
specifically so for example with cloud C
iron iron blade has the ability called
triple slash while Buster sword has the
ability called
focus thrust and so those both each have
their own ability on top of that you can
add extra abilities using materia
there's some that like will add an
ability that you can use and then there
are also ones that add magic and then
when you swap your weapons around you
can like move all your materia over
basically like materia levels up
independently and so you could like I
could theoretically like level up my
materia to like a certain like rank and
have like a higher level heal spell and
then I can give it to a different
character who's never used it and
they'll just have that high rank spell
so it gives you a lot of flexibility
which I really really like yeah the the
materia system in seven is really pretty
good interesting and then you get into
like the links materia slots that have
combos and stuff you can do and I'm I'm
kind of sad because I know that down the
line you get weapons that have like
eight different material aughts and like
six of them are linked so you can do
combination stuff that's really cool and
I don't think any of that's kind of show
up in this game because of how much more
of this game there is
I have a question I was talking about
this with Matt so do you think that
eventually how they gonna handle the
multiple parts of this like do you think
they're going to have straight up like
like are they going to find a way to
fuse them all together so you can play
it as one continuous game once it's all
out or is your character gonna carry
over is your equipment gonna carry over
like how do you think they're gonna
handle that it'll probably be similar to
how the disks worked where it would just
say like end of part 1 get ready for
parts I was saying I kind of hope they
like making homage to the disks and say
like what if like you were playing and
they're like oh insert disc 2 to keep
playing insert part 2 yeah so I think
they might do something like do you
think do things this way to carry over
like equipment and like levels and stuff
oh yeah they have to I think that they
they wouldn't make this like a like ah
you can drop in in part two I must third
I hope they don't do that that'd be
weird I don't know how they're gonna
handle it yeah but then again if you pay
$60 for part one you gotta pay $60 for
part two you don't want to have people
have to like invest 120 dollars to play
the first half of Final Fantasy 7
totally but yeah
a part based game yeah they they went
nuts they blew like a 7-hour part of the
game into a forty-hour part of a game
and I will say from my experience Grenaa
dive never played the original so I
don't have any you know context for that
but nothing it doesn't feel like a like
a five to seven hour narratives stretch
to 40 in like a bad way you know what I
mean where it feels like you're just
adding filler like everything that
that's in this all feels like very
necessary it feels like they added a lot
to the narrative that's like just
flashes it out and gives more characters
that were like had bit roles greater
wait it all like it to me it just feels
really good it just feels like a good
narrative like nothing about it feels
like they were just trying to fill in
for time the fact that they're giving me
more biggs and wedge and jesse is
exactly what and they're great they're
really good characters i cry enjoy him
because they were they were good but
they were almost non-existent before
like there there were named characters
that showed up for like four scenes and
there wasn't much in between as an
official the next release will be on
disk we don't know anything officially
but we know that the game is gonna be in
parts yeah they haven't said that yeah
i'm curious like do you sell it as a
different disc do you eventually like
rename this this version because you
don't just call it final fantasy remake
would you like rename it final fantasy
remake part one like i divide by one and
then it's all like dlc add-ons after
that i feel like that would really limit
their sales though I don't know I really
definitely yeah but who would be buying
part three and not part one and two you
know I mean that's true you probably
shouldn't ask about the story this game
I think it's great I really really like
it I like the characters a whole lot you
know again I like wasn't expecting to I
sort of was like ah you know it's file
fantasy in cloud he's an emo boy and
it's all very anime but like I the suits
are like really endearing that's the
other problem too is
now that I played the game I cloud isn't
so much emo as much as he's just a jerk
like he's a jerk in this too but I think
they do a really good job it's setting
up why he is the way he is and then also
like melting his icy heart like that's
actually like a really major part of the
narrative and this one is like it's
about cloud like learning to be a better
person
yeah and actually as a grower Wayne says
in the show there is gonna be a day one
patch for texture stuff in this game so
that's all there is
okay I'm very curious about that because
um in my experience I would say like the
parts that are meant to look really good
and look really good like all the
characters look great you know like a
lot of the cutscenes there are some
textures that kind of look a little
money a couple like door textures and
things like that that I normally doesn't
bother me but I do think like
occasionally they're kind of in the
foreground of a cutscene in a way that
you're like ooh that looks a little
rough but if they're if they're day one
patching at the vets that's great yeah
I'd love to see this game on PC and how
good it could look oh yeah and that's
the other thing too like liquid saying
if it were DLC editions that's so a lot
of people don't have the Internet yes
exactly
well you wonder like again once they
finish it do you think they'll sell like
a complete edition Oh babies everything
and it runs on one continuous thing and
it's 200 gigabytes or whatever and you
you can click this out or whatever I'm
calling it like in 12 years when we get
the last part it's gonna be called Final
Fantasy 7 remake complete oh yeah
there's one thing well what did they
well they call the Royal Edition is what
they called 15 oh yeah cuz that's that's
like a tie to the story kind of deal
though
what if they call the digital complete
version cloud Edition oh there you go I
love it
we'll be streaming games by then somehow
stadia we'll figure it sits stuff out
yeah yeah we'll make it they'll make a
special stadia version they call
yeah cloud cloud in the cloud yeah cloud
addiction are you guys gonna get a hard
copy
I bought it digitally I got the digital
deluxe one I kind of wish that I got the
really expensive just because I really
like this game and I like buying
physical copies of games that I really
really like so like it was something
that I wasn't originally planning on it
but now that I've like really really
liked this game I sort of want to buy a
physical copy yeah that'd probably be
for a while I'll probably wait that that
figure though I didn't realize it wasn't
a statue and I really I'm kicking myself
for not buying yeah waffle neurons is
extremely excited for this but it's a
bit lame it's only the first part of it
yeah
it's fair but there's there's some about
Midgar in the original game that I think
a lot of people it's something that
invites kind of exploration and maybe
there was more that they could
definitely spend time expanding on them
for it mm-hmm it if you're gonna blow up
one part of the game it feels like this
was the most logical part to blow up
sure yeah somebody mentioned HDR in the
chat I actually haven't messed I've
played a little bit with HDR I'm mostly
not because I've been like capping the
game and I have to like have that off
for capture purposes it looks good
though like when I've when I've played
it on my like TV it looks great with all
the little bells and whistles turned on
there is a part of me that's really said
that this isn't on pc i now write be
really good
let's get in here also is weird hearing
voices oh sure yeah cuz they didn't talk
on the original right now is just alt
text also you if you tried the like the
Japanese or some curious if that if
that's a good option so I might do that
I'm curious to see what I hear though I
like the English voice acting quite a
bit actually yeah I hear the English
voice acting is pretty good I also hear
that the lip-synching is done just to
Japanese yeah part of me that I would
say that's more noticeable in
side-quests where you could tell like
the lip-syncing is is not they didn't
put as much effort into it versus like
the major cutscenes it's something I
didn't really notice in the major and
all the big major cutscenes like that's
I never noticed the lip-syncing being
off at all I'm sure if I was to like
really really scrutinize it it wouldn't
maybe not be quite as perfect but not
it's really just the the side stuff that
I I only ever notice it's not perfect so
rogue leader ass is only half the game
or a section worth be multiple games to
get the entire experience so this this
game Final Fantasy 7 remake is based off
of like a single 10 hour section of a 40
hour role-playing game less than that
even
III finished Midgar in like five or six
hours in the original right but this is
just that one section blown up and
they're planning on doing multiple
releases down the road yeah you know
obviously everyone's gonna feel
differently about it and I never played
the original so I don't have my
perspective is different but at least in
my opinion I feels very much like a
complete story
I forget who in the in the chat in our
like GameSpot chat compared it to like
the Star Wars trilogy where it just
feels like this feels like your new hope
you know
some I'm really curious how this is
gonna end that's the thing I also
haven't beaten it yet so maybe my
opinion will change the vanity but at
least like tomorrow seemed very like hey
it obviously
ends with like you know there's gonna be
more but like he he he said he seemed to
think that it ended in a satisfactory
way where it feels like the specific
overarching narrative they were trying
to tell within this specific game was
concluded and felt satisfactory yeah I'm
what you can't leave off as soon as you
leave Midgar cuz that's too open-ended I
feel like they're probably gonna have to
take it in a little bit like you have to
get to the part right afterwards kind of
makes sense I'm curious I'm curious
where exactly but I haven't played it so
I can't tell but right that's that's
what I'm wondering about are going to
talk about boy sadly here Brendon says
I'm sure that after dark podcast
tomorrow will be more Final Fantasy talk
oh yeah
if you want to hear Final Fantasy talk
to more tomorrow talks at length me as
well I'm on that one this week so that's
pretty pretty Brad already did that not
me I just didn't do enough we go to
assess more assess even more things get
all the little things let's go to her I
don't know if I I called this out Aziz
asks is this on a ps4 Pro or not this is
not important this is not a pro it's not
a pro I'm not playing it in 1080p or any
era I'm not playing in 4k or anything
I'm playing in 1080p I think I have the
boost mode enabled I think go to the
boost mood on all the time I don't know
how much that affects the game I haven't
checked I'm sure if you want like a full
tech breakdown I know digital digital
foundry I'm sure will have although
there's all these videos that's that's
who I always recommend people go check
out when you're curious about that kind
of stuff
I mean just look at that though like oh
that looks like look at that
do I it's like I realized that it's
fully the entire time I've been looking
at this not being able to pull my eyes
away from it and it means I'm not
looking anywhere near my camera and I
hate that no that's okay it looks so
good
Tifa you won't believe it
James says characters popping out as a
shame but the frame rate is on point
yeah again frame rate is been on point
except for that earlier part in the
stream where that was the stream not me
seems to be fixed now that which is
great but yeah like the popin it's I can
understand that being a little
irritating for some people personally I
didn't bother me too much because like I
said I think the parts that are supposed
to look good look real good but I am
curious how that day one patch changes
things if they are if they do have one
that will add layers okay so now I need
to go get this other thing you know what
the the biggest worst thing that has
happened out of me playing Final Fantasy
7 finally and I was worried it was gonna
happen was what I've gone back and I've
tried playing as cloud and Smash
Brothers I'm like that's not bad
Oh No cuz you hate clouds yeah I do he
had no right being there until they
finally put Final Fantasy 7 on a
Nintendo console and now you're like
give me more cloud clouds cool oh I
don't know if I meant to give me more
cloud yet but I meant though I gotta get
this I get it it's really cool actually
the music every time the soundtrack in
this game is fantastic also I really
like the I remember these enemies
specifically because they would grab on
to the characters in the original one
and construct them too so that's great
it's great to see that they still do
that let's do my triple flash there we
go nice these guys are pretty easy not
too much of a challenge compared to
other areas so I can't really show off
like the full breadth of the combat like
it gets the combat it's so crazy later
on where you are like you have to be
like constantly like pausing and
juggling characters and abilities like
the combat is no joke in this game it
gets really intense and it's super
satisfying I think it's I honestly think
it's like the best Final Fantasy combat
in terms of modern games you know like I
felt like they've never they've never
always quite worked for me like I
thought 15s was kind of a little messy
15 just had no impact and that was my
biggest it felt like I was just hitting
buttons you know right like I wasn't
really thinking about it and everything
kind of felt real loose this it feels
like the hits feel good and then it
feels like you really have to like
strategically think about what you're
doing because if you're just like I'm
just gonna mash the button you're gonna
die like really easily yeah I think the
demo gave a pretty good example of that
yeah but I would say like there's even
later doing like juggling where people
are mm-hmm
like it's it's not like as intense as it
probably gets but it was a good kind of
like oh you have to dodge things you
have to be positioned correctly you have
to hit things in the right spot you have
to know weaknesses and where to hit
things with them and totally well I had
some kind of like Monster Hunter vibes
to it which Imbruglia does we'll have a
little bit of Monster Hunter vibes and I
would say like once you have three party
members and you're like juggling all
that it's it's it's a lot but in like a
great way you feel it feels really good
yeah a waffle wants to know what tifa's
triangle ability does oh yes so tifa's
whole thing is that she is
is really good for like building up
stagger meter which is like key in this
games combat so if I switch over to T fo
so her basic triangle is just a uppercut
but you can see did a lot because these
guys are really easy so what I do is I
hit this ability here called unbridled
strength it switches my triangle to a
thing called Omni strike which is like a
more powerful strike but also her hands
are glowing now and so I do more basic
damage and I do more stagger damage and
if I don't get interrupted I can keep
showing it off and then I can boost it a
second time so if I do it once more all
right or the combat will end on her show
but her hands will glow red and so you
can boost it twice and she'll do even
more basic damage and more stagger
damage so the whole idea with like Tifa
is you is you build up her you boost
your speed and you boost her like her
per meter speed and you just use her
abilities to build up stagger really
quickly and you have her like stagger
everybody and then you switch over to
someone like cloud and then you just hit
them with like real heavy damage so it
it didn't make me oh I didn't realize it
until way later on like what the
character archetypes were in this
because I played a lot of Final Fantasy
14 and I love that teef is just like a
really good like monk got a job
archetype and that she kind of has a lot
of emphasis on not just because she
punches people but her ability is kind
of stacked that way yeah I never knew
that yuffie was a ninja so I learned
that but it's kind of cool to see that
reflected on everything cuz I've only
got the finger reference before teen at
this point right but even then it's not
like you're really like super lot like
you know obviously like teeth is really
good for like stagger and that's kind of
her specialty but because of the way the
mana system works you're not locked into
like who can lengthen magic and you can
really mix it up and I do think that's
cool
in the the end of my playthrough Tifa
was actually my main healer okay
see like Barrett's my main healer and
what I've been playing he makes sense
because he can sit back and actually
like pick things off and I guess there
is like in the old game you could change
where you were party wise like forwards
backwards but I'll just kind of kind of
fell that way I guess say I guess now I
got that to for going teef is never
gonna leave my party it's a good call
fortunately I don't think you have no
party stuff to worry about yes part of
the game I'm curious how they'll handle
it in the later ones because in this
part of the game it's basically all
story dependent on who you have and
there's only really the four party
members so you're nothing it'll open up
later on well right yeah and like the
other parts but in this in this one in
particular it's very much just like you
have the four characters and you're
playing who you are at that point in the
story which is interesting interesting
way to do it I also like the there are a
lot of story points where they force you
to play party members that aren't just
like who you want to play yep I
appreciate those because they make me
realize that I need to actually spend
time on other people it does it
definitely makes me um learn how to play
those characters jeez I always the one
enemies I don't care for in this game
are like flying enemies cuz it's it's so
limits what you can do like until he
pops to the ground like this all of
clouds like abilities are useless oh
yeah unless you got like a like fire
probably yes so you like magic and stuff
but in terms of his basic attacks like
you can't do any of that stuff sorry I
personally find that rather obnoxious
it's gonna be three or four in battle I
think three is the most you can still
have I think it's yeah I think it's
three as well I haven't I don't think
they'd mess with the formula too much I
not at the end of the game but so I
don't know if the changes near the very
end but for the majority of the game
I've only been able to have a max of 3
so you your party members you have now
our T fo Barrett and cloud and that's it
I mean like in your playthrough or not
not necessarily this one oh Aerith
Aerith is the fourth one ok do you have
anyone else yet nope
oh you've still got a ways to go not
done yet
yeah yeah is this you guys favourite
game of the year so far I am
anticipating it I haven't played it yet
outside of the demo it might be one of
my favorite it's it's really up there
for me and it's a surprise because I'm
you like I wasn't expecting it III would
have to think about it this year has
been a weird blur for me I'm like trying
to think about like what else even
happened this year because this year has
been a billion years in one and but I
would say the two games that have really
stuck with me in a big way is this game
and half-life Alex are the two that I
like vividly I'm like yes those games
are amazing I still need to finish
half-life and I deserve action I also
need to finish resident evil 3 remake
cuz I was like I'm gonna take my time
that games I can beat it in two sittings
probably so just come back to an event
we definitely never came back but I
would also say yeah you should like it's
it's a game that like has a momentum to
it where you probably shouldn't like
stop and then ya pick it back up you
should probably just play in like two
goes this way there's a little thing I
want you know you feel instant and an
even Barrett are good anti-air people
for sure I'm really curious how all that
stuff's gonna feel later on
waffles didn't like doom eternal Oh what
we like doom but you know what both of
us like give eternal I do
doom Eternals real good ID man I feel
bad I like forgot about doom eternal
know do meet Charles grace just the
powerful face
about bed it feels like doom eternal
came out three years ago not like it it
came out an eternity ago a doom eternal
ago
Emilio says oMG John the finished
half-life Alex I think he means me I
should finish half-life Alex no I
haven't either I was saying I also
happen we should all have finished it
should all finish half like that I'm
gonna show you to finish it
now be my dad that's this weekend that's
my plan
James is I think just not figuring out
that cloud isn't smash yes yes boy isn't
smash that's good news for you cloud is
and smash brothers unless you're just
saying it because you're excited then I
feel that here we go giving this kid my
Intel so this guy's interesting because
he basically as you do these like you
you like find battle data for him as you
play the game and like fight monsters
is this your [ __ ] yes you're not gonna
stop I'm not gonna see it right here
though I want to see you fight Shiva
why are you no you know I you know what
if we have a little bit of time would
you like me to swap ahead and fight do a
VR fight I'd like to see V afraid okay
do it no no no no if you want we could
we could we can move ahead to one more
part of the games all right I trust
you're driving all right give me a sec
I'm going to load two I hope that I
already I didn't already do the fight
we'll find out I might have already Mary
we'll see
looks like hope from Final Fantasy 13
yeah kinda I can see that he's I was
annoying now I hate hope he's just Ken
from persona 3 who I also hate he's
literally the same character with the
same storyline I hate him oh yeah but
Ken got really good in the fighting game
though Ken did get really good in the
fighting game but he's still yeah yeah
maybe hope got better in a 13-2 but I on
play that so
there was he's better than lightning
returns cuz he's not even in it I
actually want to make a run back at 13
to in in my tweet that I made no one
said that I should play 13 so higher I
started downloading 13 again not my xbox
dude are you I read downloaded it just
this morning because I was thinking of
like as I was thinking of doing the
tweet okay a little later in the game
again no story spoilers but we now have
our girl Arif who by the way I just want
to say Aerith is absolutely melts your
heart like from the from the gecko
immediately fell in love she's good
she's so just a good voice actor it's
amazing oh when it asks you for her name
is a desk for eros or Aerith is the
default I think it says eros
well it's okay good it doesn't let you
pick their names or anything like that
like in the original hope is in
lightning returns no Wayne say it ain't
so I might have already done he's
developed a new materia I already did it
I can redo it though if you want yeah
alright let's do it
let me just check my equipment let me
make sure I got the right [ __ ] here okay
uh does it play any different music when
you fight her there's the the same kind
of like boss fight music oh it plays
something I'm trying to remember what it
play it doesn't play the song from Final
Fantasy 14 when you fight Shiva and
that's a damn shame
okay I got the fire I'm gonna put on
like okay hold on do I have another
elemental materia shoe see that's what I
wanted a that's why I wanted to ask it
Emilio cuz I'm like ah no one's asking
the big question what did they
officially go with for her default name
and that's kind of wild to hear that
they went with Aerith I think yeah they
went with Arif cuz Aerith from again I
could be wrong about this just from a
little bit of research
is the official Japanese name but they
called her Eris in the US now they went
with era there's something for this one
that is now her official name I love it
[Music]
dang I was hoping I could get another
elemental that's okay sorry he is he's
annoying you know it's better than I
found out this way way and I'm glad that
you had to be the one to break it to me
if I ever go back to try lightning
returns yeah I mean I've already dropped
like what 15 20 hours and 13 I should
just go finish it you know I mean I say
that was like you know 10 years ago do
you want you want to do it you want to
do a DAB for for James really quick
sharp alright ready to dip fur for Club
being in smash ready alright yeah go
there you go perfect we've nailed it
sick final fantasy and dabbing all in
the same stream it's a wild Thursday I
like to follow yours attack with a want
to put that on Arif then Brandon is
asking what are we doing for community
Friday that's a great question we
honestly still haven't figured it out
which is you know how you got to do it
sometimes
she's got prior used to be focus okay
it's a good opportunity to tell you guys
who are here now you should subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss a single
show we do we go live every weekday at 2
p.m. Pacific I'm sure that John Luke and
I usually do isn't on a Wednesday or
Thursday it's on a Friday which is
tomorrow and we play games with you guys
hey yeah we don't know what we're
playing tomorrow though so well what if
we just do PSO this week like we could
do though that'd be fun man just throw
it we're hooking up never vr ah combat
simulator oh yeah it's like a guitar
version
it's good it's not as good as Final
Fantasy 14 theme for but it's good okay
let's do this
love you too don't
ah thanks liquid I'm glad that you like
this week we try to do what we can in
these uncertain times to provide some
sort of I don't know fun thing even for
just like an hour and a half every day
so you guys can have a good time this is
really good actually
it's really good today I'll show you the
music that they had for for Final
Fantasy 14 for her no actually oh you
don't have a hot bummer it plays this
really good piano violin like a melody
through the first half of the fight and
then when you get to like 50% she snaps
freezes the entire stage that everyone's
on and then steps on someone and breaks
all of the ice at once and then this
j-rock Garage Band blowing that's pretty
good
song starts playing that sounds like an
anime Opie and for the whole rest of the
fight it's just this like it's got
lyrics it's got it's really good I
should I should probably link it to you
at some point it's a two-player it's not
two-player it I realize that a stream
set up might make people think that it's
two-player but it is now now
sorry it's sorry hon do it show me what
you could do I guess it's not drink
spelling bangers yeah I'm really
wondering how how many of these be are
things still eventually having I've only
found one I know there's at least a
couple but that menu like implies like
20 yeah I wonder if they'll add any is
like DLC for just like people just to go
in and do yeah I am I'm so slow as soon
as it hits nine o'clock tonight I'm on
to find me this is where I'm gonna be
yeah English voice acting is pretty good
I like it I'm actually surprised that I
haven't heard a lot of repeating
dialogue so far there's definitely some
it's a video game but I'm sure I've here
it will eventually be nothing I've not
obnoxious or anything like that if
that's what you're worried about
yeah shoot Shira from Final Fantasy or
Shira from Mortal Kombat mm-hmm so it's
a tough that's a tough question
Mortal Kombat Shiva has multiple arms
but she reformed Final Fantasy is pretty
cool goddang she keeps a stunning cloud
for me it's nice fun oh cloud just got
hurt real bad
do you instantly die when she steps on
you when you're frozen nah it just kind
of breaks the ice and then the fight
starts over again at least in in 14 okay
I don't even know she steps on you in
this let's use that windbreaker
oh there you go
so notice that in in this save he went
back to using the regular Buster Sword -
yes Oh got a summon out yep yep yep I
should be able to do I not have it
she hasn't quit okay that's fine yeah
she's sharing hold it out I think didn't
she not yet Oh Manuel wants to know
quick question are there miscible items
as you progress through the game I'm
sure that there will be there are there
definitely all right there's a there's a
summon I missed oh there we go there's a
summon I'll say right now there's
someone in chapter 6 that don't mean I
don't keep an eye out for that one I
missed it and I was like oh I'm a fool
cuz there's a lot of miscible stuff in
the original game all right I'm gonna
heal Aerith because she can't die cuz
that'll mess up her summon
it looks so good oh yeah yeah yeah
get a set if that looks really good -
I'm not I'm not big into towing is that
who do radiant bloom yes
heck yeah and you got 1080p for that oh
I like that the victory fanfare kind of
thing pretty good a VR suite well
there's an example of of that those are
fun I like doing this yeah and the fact
that there's gonna be more of them makes
me looks like say I really like the
combat when I play the demo and I just
want to kind of really fun ya know we
got a couple more minutes could just run
around show off some stuff oh yeah I
keep forgetting that we keep we can only
do an hour and now right yeah you're
like oh we'll go for yeah we pose like
we've got like another half hour
it knows like we don't know I can't
that's alright go we got rules to follow
but it's fine we don't want to show off
too much of it yeah I'll spell too much
for anyone I can't I can't wait I can't
wait I need to play it now open world
yes it's it's kind of an open explorable
only open h i would say it's not open
world than the in the traditional sense
but you have these pockets of open areas
that have you know shops and side quests
it's it's not like don't don't think
it's Final Fantasy 15 it's not that yes
it I would say it's more in line with
the way like actual original version of
worked right were you it's like kind of
these like small in your areas and that
kind of opens up to these slightly
expanded areas where you can go do side
quests and some like that sounds like
it's more like Yakuza to me it is
there's some there's some yeah keys of
vibes Ben I was think about muscles and
then tomorrow said as well and I was
like yeah I had to say I had to bring it
out and let the people know alright
let's see if I can do this my should
play on kazoo I remember this fight
being kind of tough
cuz these boys love to stun yeah yep
there you go
you really gotta time your attacks
because if you get hit and knocked out
of it not only do you not do attack but
it wastes your ATV bar and it sucks
sweet love you guys my video thanks
James
appreciate it shoot I also like uh
airless like dodge is just kind of like
a well you're well sight
yeah yeah
can you summon the DLC animals in the
beginning or later did you two guys get
codes for the I think so I didn't get
any codes for the extra DLC summons so
unfortunately I couldn't tell you
anything about that dang cuz that I'm
real stoked about that
that chocobo baby one I'm stoked about
that cacked r1 No sab sab attender or
whatever the cold oh my gosh that's
exactly it
what Jacques the seven jackals have
become I don't fantasy no fantasy has
become Yakuza lipped they traded for
2020 what is this it's good April Fool's
Day bit it really is staying hon you you
messed me up with that one not liking
any of a turn-based jock as a game
though I was first but I'm not all for
it man and there have a lot of a lot of
good friends who actually imported it
and they've already played through it
and they're like yeah I know this is
it's really good and it's yeah cuz it
through and through and that's there's
enough to it to sell me on I'm wholesale
in if that comes out this year caught it
probably gonna be my game in the year
god I hope so
who knows though so we haven't gotten
any news on it no and you know all the
current situation might might affect it
unfortunately should be yeah are you
playing with the mouse and keyboard no
you're playing with a controller back at
Raleigh I'm gonna playstation for home
entertainment console I might not kill
these guys these guys are really tough
you were looking for a fight to end out
the stream thrill you found you found
one they're stupid stunning attack
oh boy this is bad
oh yeah these guys are not taking a lot
of damage
no no they're they're really tough those
game does not look around I'm great
it's basically I just have to wait for
one of them to get hit just for them to
see and then by oh no you can't let her
die not gonna let her die not this time
not this time oh I want I want I want to
see era era throwing a grenade that's
okay that's a that's a mood if we can
make it can be made to happen I don't
remember what these guys are week two
and the old game but here yes yes yes
got 15 of these there yeah I actually
didn't use a lot of my items in my
playthrough so I I have like a ton of
all that stuff lapped over him oh dang
it
man there I go oh that's right it's it
was it was a big it was a big fight now
we get to see what happens when you get
a game over yeah
oh I like the definitely not PlayStation
menu in that possibly I thought the same
thing like that that's a hundred percent
just the dashboard yeah I totally
thought the same thing well yeah that's
been about an hour so I would say that's
a good place to stop sorry had to be a
little bit of a shorter stream today but
them's the rules
we gotta say okay but I hope this was a
decent little taste of the game for
people spoiler free as we said and I'm
hope you guys are excited to play it
tomorrow because it's really good and
you should play it
thank yes let's do just like 100% for a
fact to know that you hate Final Fantasy
then I guess you probably won't like it
but and that's cool too you know and I'm
glad that you're here to hear that even
if you don't like Final Fantasy because
that means you're probably just here for
us which is very nice which is great
anything else you want to say it'd been
before we close out for today uh don't
be a fool stay in school play Jacquizz a
play duggan drop a play final fantasy
mm-hmm and giants tomorrow and play some
fantasy star because i think that's what
we go thank you
i starship to write of ship to ship to
so yeah ship to baby
well what we'll just hang around didn't
have a good time with that so stick
around for that guys and see you next
time
[Music]